Oh
thank you very much I don't
I don't know where we're getting the
crowds lately but it's a lot better than
when we got them for the first 12 years
I just but I you know I say this every
week so I know my credibility is thin
when I say I know why you're happy but I
think I really mean it this time
I know why you're happy Hillary Clinton
said today she is a big announcement on
Sunday what could it be
oh my god I'm not going to get any sleep
Saturday night wondering no no we know
what it is she's playing spider-man one
more time it's gonna be good no she's
going to announce that she's running for
president of course she's going to do it
interesting first in an email blast
which yes republic republicans found
this very ironic because email as we all
know is the tool she used to kill
everybody had Benghazi and then she's
been she's going off to Iowa for to film
a very sexy Spring Break video
all girls gone inevitable it's really
something
but you know what folks you look at the
polls it's gonna be Clinton and Bush
again it's it's so funny because
everybody says okay we want somebody new
and then they look at the new people
running like Ted Cruz and Rand Paul and
Marco Rubio and they go you know we need
more Clintons and bushes I it's gonna be
the 90s all over again I I'm embracing
it today I put my spin-doctor CD into my
into my discman I I went over the oxygen
bar and I called my friends I said hit
me up on pager but the other the other
candidate who threw his hat in the ring
this week of course is Rand Paul uh kind
of hit the ground sucking yeah he kind
of did I mean he was supposed to be the
one guy who was for cutting defense
that's why I liked him and now he's
standing in front of an aircraft carrier
and they asked him on NBC News why he
was flip-flopping on all the issues he
used to be good on and he had an
interesting answer he said well you know
when I was young I experimented with
integrity
no you know what he was when he was you
know he did before he went into politics
Rand Paul he was an eye doctor he's an
ophthalmologist which that training has
come in handy because every time he
switches positions
he says better like this better like
this so yeah I mean take a ran please no
he was the one guy who was kind of
sensible on that the Republican Party
now he's like I forgot the Republican
which is such a shame because you know
we're finally making progress there
after years of tough negotiations to get
Iran to give up their nuclear program we
finally got a framework we got Iran to
agree to a framework well of course now
comes the hard part because before that
can become an actual treaty uh you got
to get the approval of a faction within
the government of super-religious
hardline medieval fanatics and of course
it's not going to be an easy sell in
Iran either
alright domestic news this is little
scary a study out of Duke University
came out this week that said get this
nine percent of Americans have both
anger issues and a gun yeah they're
called cops well
yes and the category of things I never
thought I would see the police this week
admitted they got one wrong first time
I'd ever seen them do that and we've all
seen this video right from South
Carolina what what happened was a black
man was driving a Mercedes or what the
police call probable cause so the cop
pulls him over then the guy was late
with his child support payment so he
panicked and ran away and the cop shot
him in the back eight times and then of
course the cop claims that like they
always do that his life was in danger
this was the worst excuse in the world
the cop said I had to shoot him I
thought he was charging at me backwards
while shrinking
that's a terrible extrude
and finally I'm sure you heard the big
verdict came in the Boston bomber case
or nay AB guilty on all 30 counts now
they just have to decide whether he gets
the death penalty or life in prison now
I have no problem with killing this guy
but he wants to be a martyr so we're
kind of give him what he wants because
he wants to collect the 72 virgins I say
put him in prison and let him be the
virgin for 72 other guy
you